well we can continue with that
graduation theme because frankly that
was a fun one and you know the the
YouTube Facebook live streams are going
to start shortly as well I'm gonna
repeat what I just said but I will also
apologize I just had a tooth removed
I had a cracked tooth that's last week
and they had to they had to take it they
had to they had to take it out my mom
was just calling so I just had to I'll
call I'll call her back in a little bit
but I just had a cracked tooth and they
they took it out and then they screwed
in I guess the thing that they're going
to eventually have to put the implant so
much this entire half of my face is numb
and so at least today I have an excuse
to sound funny oh hey everyone now I'm
on if you see me looking away I'm now on
Facebook and YouTube so hi everyone on
Facebook and YouTube Sal here for our
daily homeroom livestream for those of
you all who are wondering what this is
this is really just something we started
when we started seeing school closures
and social distancing and we said hey
this could be a cool way for all of us
to stay in touch and sometimes I have
guests and sometimes we just do ask me
anything today the guest is me so we'll
just do ask me anything I was just
telling the Instagram crowd who is you
know a little bit lower here if you ever
see me not making eye contact they're
there right over here I guess is that me
on Instagram I don't know this is
bizarre a little bit trippy but I was
just telling them that I had a cracked
tooth as of last Friday I was eating a
peach and which is not normally a
consider to be a hard tooth shattering
thing but it did somehow crack my my
bottom left molar and so it's been
incredibly painful but considering all
this happening in the world it's as I
say it's it's on the edge of the type of
problems you want to have because
obviously there's a lot of folks going
through a lot more right now so I just
got kind of a emergency dental thing and
my this entire half of my face is numb
let me see my mom just called so loved
me she keeps calling maybe one of these
days I'll just answer the phone with my
mom that could be entertaining but yes
this this entire half of my face is is
right now numb so
I have an excuse today to sound funny
better excuse that I normally do so
before I start I do want to make my
standard announcement remind everyone
that Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
that we exist only because of
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in a position to
do so please think about making a
donation I want to give a special shout
out to several corporations that have
stepped up to support Khan Academy over
the last few weeks Bank for America
Google org 18t Novartis and fastly thank
you for that support so with that let's
let's get into the heart of it and you
know I might cut it short because all
sorts of weird things were happening in
my mouth right now and I apologize if
have to wipe my mouth but not might not
be the most pleasant viewing but yes
half of my mouth is right now numb but I
I'm a big ham habit of consistency and
habit so that's why I'm wanting to do
this regardless so please ask me
anything all right some Twitter Greg
Ferran Steen oh I know great I have so
many questions does your beard have a
nickname do you read will you read me a
bedtime calculus problem can we be
friends
well if this is the same Greg friends
team that I dunno I we're already
friends maybe this is a different Gregg
Bernstein my beard does not have a
nickname that I think would be you know
I have some eccentricities but they have
not quite gotten there yet will you read
me a bedtime calculus problem maybe
think about that
think about how we can do the logistics
I'll wait for my tooth to heal before I
think about bedtime calculus problems
okay from Facebook and you know I said
this is asking me anything and it can be
literally about anything but I thought
last week when we did the graduation
theme that was also fun because then I
got to be kind of uncle Sal and give
life advice and wisdom and and you could
take it for what it for what it's worth
so from Facebook Laurie and stiles near
I would love to see school districts
convert to using kind of coming
regularly I think the Khan the the
classroom flip students watch videos
from teachers or Khan Academy at night
and work through their assignments in
the classroom with will aid teachers why
is this approach not implemented yet so
those are
of you who don't know what Laurie is
referring to is something that we've
sometimes been associated with but it's
not something that we came up with this
notion of a flipped classroom predates
Khan Academy arguably this is what you
know Socrates did where students would
do reading ahead of time and then when
they get to class they would engage in I
guess a Socratic dialogue with Socrates
but the idea is is that the the learning
the information retrieval or coverage
happens at your own time and pace and
that's especially doable now in time
on-demand video and that way when you
get to a classroom you're able to dive
deeper do problem-solving have
conversations actually have human to
human interaction and and so that's why
people call it a flip and once you do
that you can actually go even further
because one of the reasons why a
classroom all has to move at the same
pace is because in a traditional
classroom you have a lecturer and a
lecturer by definition is at a fixed
pace but all of a sudden if students are
able to watch content or even practice
at their own time and pace on their own
then when they get to the class they can
have more supports and in theory every
student could go in a different pace and
you know I don't think it has to be
strict videos at home or lectures at
home and then problem-solving in the
classroom I actually think it could be
whether you're in the classroom or at
home you should do whatever makes sense
for you so work at your own time and
pace on exercises and videos and then
when you're in the classroom you have
extra supports of your peers your
teacher the teacher can look at the data
and see hey so until it's having problem
or maybe three students are having
trouble I can have a small group session
with them while the other students
continue to work at their own time and
pace and we've seen this in many many
classrooms and students love it because
it's much more interactive they get much
more support and teachers really like it
because they get to form these deeper
connections are really able to do
differentiated instruction to your
question of why we're not seeing more of
it I think it's just a it's a different
way of thinking about classrooms and you
know for the most part it just sometimes
takes time for people to realize there's
a shift you know I've given talks to
groups of educators and they all
intellectually really agree with this
this idea but it is sometimes harder to
move past maybe what you're used to in a
traditional model the one you know one
silver lining perhaps of the scope of
crisis is that we are seeing men
many more teachers moved to this type of
a model because obviously with people
staying at home now you're not getting
as much I guess you could say seat time
in the classroom and so a lot more of
the information delivery or the lectures
or whatever you want to call and the
problem-solving has to happen on a
student's own time and pace and that way
when students and teachers get on zoom'
or Google hangout or whatever they have
a lot more interaction because obviously
it makes no sense to just give a lecture
on zoom that might as well just be a
video and and honestly it's not that
it's not just about zoom that could be
true of the real world too if you just
if you know in some universities of the
Electra with 300 students that could and
should be a video and ideally the
students and the teachers could interact
with each other instead which would be
far more human and if you see me keep
shifting my eyes from a little part of
my screen to another it's because I'm
trying to make eye contact with both
Instagram and the Facebook YouTube live
streams and read the question so my
apologies all right there's C from
Facebook were stuck on says I hope you
don't mind but I tell people that you're
my cousin sounds fine to me for all we
know we are cousins cousin orsa alright
there are YouTube at four Easton asks if
you taught in a public school what would
you teach you know one of the things
that I when I was in college I used to
say if there was such a thing as a PhD
and everything that's what I would want
to do because I actually can get very
excited about teaching almost anything
or or learning about almost anything so
you know math is interesting physics
chemistry biology I would love to do
literature I would love a philosophy
course I think that's what keeps things
interesting is where you you you you
want to teach things where you have you
have some grounding and familiarity but
it's also fun to be on that learning
journey often times with the students
and often times that makes the teaching
that much more authentic because you're
that much closer to empathizing with the
experience that the students are having
at that moment but you know in in-person
classrooms I really like as much
interactivity as possible you know we
started a little Lab School
it's in our offices called con lab
school and uh you know roughly once a
week or once a month I do a seminar with
the the middle and upper school students
and that we just kind of you know I
start with a question I just say what is
the meaning of life a small question and
then and then really facilitate a
Socratic dialogue so I like doing things
like that or like doing simulations and
games with students and I liked it I
like it when you're when you get into
the room the more cross-disciplinary it
could be so oftentimes in that hour we
will go into philosophy politics
economics physics math and and I think
that's what really forms the connections
for for students and frankly I learned
something interesting every time I do it
I think the some of the fun is when it's
not predictable when when you know from
the it's not just from the teacher to
the student but it's also from the
students to each other and to the the
teacher as well let's see from Facebook
Ganesh Gallup Ali do you have any plans
to translate content in English saying
Indian languages simple answers yes we
have a whole effort going on in India we
have a team in Delhi and in Bangalore
that is redoing and translating content
into the largest Indian languages we
also have a project in English for those
of you who are not familiar that is a
hybrid of Hindi and English which is
apparently a fairly standard method of
learning a lot of topics or the language
of Education a lot of North India so
yeah we we are doing that simple answer
so look look that up look up you know
Khan Academy India and I think you
should be able to find that ok from
Facebook Kesava Rahman asks how long did
you study and how long do you recommend
study how are you motivated to study
when you were young so I guess that
question you know new men mean how many
years did I go to school or when I
studied in school how long did I study I
guess I'll answer both in terms I guess
the first ones easier to answer I you
know my undergrad I did a master's
degree but that all of that stuff
happened in about 4 years and that was
the CS and math and and a master's in
computer science Electrical Engineering
and then I went to business school for
two years
you can you know you can add up and then
I was working for two and a half years
between undergraduate and business
schools so that's how long I went to
school formal school thing I guess you
could say in terms of how long did I
study it really depended on the context
depending what I was doing at the time
what I found in courses like math and
physics and chemistry and biology
essentially stem courses or or even you
know programming courses I found that if
you do the problem sets and you're
always just thinking about it then you
actually don't need to do a lot of
studying or a lot of cramming if you
know the professor is about to do a
problem try to do it ahead of time we're
trying to do it at the same time that
the professor's doing it if you're doing
all of the problem sets you're doing all
the projects I found that that the tests
are actually quite intuitive you know I
have peers and I don't think it's
anything about intelligence who
sometimes would you know they're kind of
mindlessly note-taking in a class and
maybe not actively learning and then
they find that when they go right before
the final exam they have to do a lot of
cramming and so I'm a much bigger fan of
active learning
you know I in enrollment old schoolhouse
I was a little bit infamous in college
that you know certain lectures I found a
lot of value in and I found that I could
do that active learning and I could and
then others I did not and so I didn't go
to them and instead I would go and I
would get out the textbook and I would
do problems on my own and I found if I
did that all term that when I got to the
class that I would you know when I got
to the exam I had to do a lot less real
studying but other subjects that might
have had you know more content to them
or more terminology you know I I wish I
could say that I wasn't you know a super
procrastinator but there were times in
college that I pulled all-nighters and
you know and and and and and in in
hindsight I wish that I had done it more
regularly you know the more mature kind
of you know fully developed frontal lobe
Sal would have said yeah you know if I
just worked on it a couple hours every
day then I would have not had to pull
those all-nighters but you know in
college you might find yourself you know
three four five six hours the night
before test if you haven't been doing
what you're supposed to up until then
you might have to do that type of thing
but I don't I don't condone it but yeah
you know you're gonna have to be the
judge yourself
of how much to study but I think the
most important thing in everything in
life you know I say this about Khan
Academy don't it's okay to binge do it
every now and then but the better is to
form a regular habit 20 30 40 minutes a
day and anything is going to actually
build those muscles and frankly not only
will you not have to cram for the test
but you're likely to have better
retention because often times you just
cram for the test you take the test you
go sleep for 16 hours and you wake up
you're like what just happened you might
not remember a lot of what just happened
alright from so so there's from Facebook
oh this duo this do khanacademy duo tell
us tell us tell us uh uh your tell us
why you love some of your favorite
science fiction authors please and then
Dan from Khan Academy is asking do noir
Foundation which one do you prefer and
why so to answer duo you know some of my
well the the the second question from
Dan kind of answers you know I'm a big
arthur c-- clark fan obviously kind of
the whole 2001 series the the whole
notion of I also like childhoods end
there's a bunch of good arthur c clarke
stuff that are that are very enjoyable
isaac ask them off i've talked a lot
about george herbert dude i mean you can
see behind me a lot of these books are
there where's the dune but you know I'm
not a big believer it's in stack ranking
everything in your life you know it's
like stack ranking your children you
love them all and they all add
dimensions to to to your life but I'll
tell you why I loved many of these
things you know foundation I've talked
about it money many times the foundation
series I'm not giving the plot away
there's a lot of it's a good read
and I envy any of y'all who haven't read
it because you get to enjoy it for the
first time but it takes place thirty
thousand years in the future humanity
has colonized the galaxy and there is
kind of this mathematician historian you
know psychologist type academic named
Harry Selden who develops this science
of psycho history and he threw his math
shows that there's a very high
probability that the Galactic Empire is
about to enter into a ten thousand year
dark ages and he decides to do something
about it his math shows him his science
shows him that if he's able to collect
the galaxies the civilizations knowledge
and put it in the periphery of the
galaxy as a foundation that will shorten
the dark ages from 10,000 years to 1,000
years and you know when I read that as a
kid I think I first read it in middle
school I was like this is epic you know
first of all it was the first time that
I really appreciated that you know what
Harry Selden is right if it the single
most important nugget for civilization
or for people is at the end of the day
how much they're able to leverage their
human potential and that all boils down
to really knowledge and so that's number
one and and and that probably put a seed
in my mind later on when I was working
on Khan Academy that like this could
matter a lot maybe Khan Academy could be
this foundation for the world that can
maybe prevent us from getting into a
dark age or maybe elevate humanity to a
whole other level whatever else and and
the other thing that I was inspired by
by Harry Selden was that he thought on
that timeframe you know most of us do
not think oh what's going to happen in a
thousand years what can I help to keep
you know that that 10,000 years of pain
and war and famine instead being 1,000
years because most of us said well you
know I probably got another 100 60 years
on this planet at best I mean many of
you young people watching hopefully will
have many many more years and you know
we can talk about you know this what
this whole notion of the singularity and
and and if medical science can extend
lifespans who knows there might be some
generation that lives much much longer
actually think we're gonna bring David
Sinclair who's done research on that
onto our livestream at some point but
you know I was inspired that by well
maybe we should be thinking on that type
type of a timeframe because that that's
probably what's going to help humanity
and it doesn't have to be ten thousand
years or a thousand years but even think
on a hundred year time frame or a 50
year time frame which I found incredibly
inspiring and that I've told many of
y'all that was one of the reasons why I
set up kind of gotta be as a
not-for-profit it was delusional ten
years ago when I was operating in this
very same walk-in closet and I'm in
right
and but I said you know maybe Khan
Academy could be like the foundation it
could serve one day billions of kids for
hundreds of years and be one of the
great institutions of the world and it
was frankly outright delusional back
then but it's feeling a lot less
delusional now you know we have a
hundred million registered users there's
no reason that can't get we've grown a
hundredfold over the last ten years
why couldn't we grow another tenfold and
get to a billion and really build out
the content and the software and the
tools and all the stuff so that we
really you know that no matter where you
are born if you at least have access to
a low-cost device and the devices are
getting cheaper every day and an
internet access that you have a lifeline
it could be in some village that you
know has no school you still have a
lifeline or it could be a place that
does have a school and then you're able
to use this thing to empower the school
to empower the teachers so that you get
more personalization and more access to
more content and you know there's ideas
of you know ways to pair people so that
one student could tutor another student
even if they're in completely different
places or different countries so anyway
that's Foundation doing is is really you
know doing is epic because it also takes
place I think several thousand years in
the future and you know it's obviously
it's it's it's a it's kind of an
allegory for the whole you know energy
and whether you know people what many
would argue that you know because of oil
in the Middle East that has become made
the Middle East a very tough you know
there's especially coming out of World
War one when people realize that oil was
very valuable and the Ottoman Empire was
broken up you know many people that's
why you've had that instability because
there's been so much interest in in in
oil which is you know obviously it could
be an issue of national security and
definitely an issue of economic security
and so dune takes place I think 3,000
years in the future but it's the same
thing that there's this planet Arrakis
that you can mine spice and spice is
used by the navigators to be able to do
interstellar travel and so it's
analogous to oil but that makes a Rakus
which has a lot of parallels to the
Middle East it's kind of a desert planet
and and it has some of these you know
there's some nomadic people who live
there but it makes them kind of a
tension point and soul just kind of a
power grab there so it's a good metaphor
for geopolitics and politics and but
then there's also a bit of a
metaphysical layer on it where the the
main character is kind of perceived as
the kind of the savior and on a
religious level you know there's this
concept in Islam known as the Mandi
which is kind of the the savior the
person you know the person who comes at
you know at some future point and and
and and and so this the people who live
on Arrakis are kind of this neo Islamic
you know you can imagine how religions
might evolve over thousands of years and
so they still have retained and they
think this the main character is that
and he has he does seem to have certain
powers or data points to to back that up
so anyway as you can imagine anything
that is truly epic and expands your mind
and makes you kind of think beyond the
oh I have to go to a dentist appointment
to remove my tooth or you know I better
go buy some baking soda tonight and
instead makes you think about like wow
what are we and where are we in the
whole scope of time and space and what
could we become as a civilization I
think is always really interesting you
know I think we sometimes forget that we
are we are we are an intermediary on
some form of pathway of some form of you
know humanity a thousand years from that
might be very very different than then
he managed today but we you know us the
collective we are the people who are
going to kind of define what that
trajectory is so it's just really
interesting things to think about so
let's see Virender budge wani asks what
are the top challenges for Khan Academy
to scale their product from just add on
education become an official part of
school curriculum specifically in
developing countries like Pakistan and
India where government school systems
can benefit a lot from Khan Academy well
there's a lot of things you know you
know at the beginning of this I made my
standard plug for resources you know
we're the budget of a large high school
that it is a substantial budget but
we're the budget of a large high school
but we reach over a hundred million
students in a year so I you know I'd
like to make the argument it's a very
strong social return on investment and
that could one day be billions we need
to add more content you know we're
starting to add English and
which artist I would looked at and
medical middle school science we already
have really math from pre-k with Khan
Academy kids all the way through high
school and early college level a math
the sciences biology chemistry and
physics are either added or being
improved upon as we speak and then so I
think that lays a very strong scaffold
we all we want to constantly improve the
software the exercises on Khan Academy
so you get as much practice and feedback
as you need we're constantly looking at
the data so that we can improve those
items you know I'm intrigued by things
in the future
how can you use Khan Academy as evidence
for what you know to the broader world
so it can plug you in into higher
education or you can even get a job or
whatever else from Khan Academy and then
I think there is a very real issue of
device access and training and support
and we are starting to do that type of
work we're working with school districts
mainly in the US but we do have efforts
in places like India and Brazil as well
to start integrating with their
technology and their rostering systems
and do training with their teachers and
their administrators and then you know
you can imagine device access especially
in places like India or Pakistan are not
where they need to be in order to fully
leverage Khan Academy to empower
teachers and students in schools but you
know my hope is over the next 10 years a
lot of that stuff is going to happen and
frankly the kovat crisis is accelerating
a lot of that so let's see there if from
Instagram w0 7 says do you play an
instrument I I do kind of I play guitar
I'm you know I'm a I'm a mediocre
guitarist I usually it's more of a means
to an end to just to sing and I'm
mediocre at that as well I've picked up
a little bit of piano my my oldest son
is actually quite good at piano and I've
kind of observed what he's been up to
and so but even there you know my piano
is really just an excuse to to belt out
a tune every now and then so let's see
we have oh we only have a little bit
more time so let's see ours is there any
any other questions so a couple of
people are asking about the jr.
breakthrough challenge Katie a you and
Natalie Oh advice for the breakthrough
junior challenge
excited about the jr. breakthrough
challenge first of all I am excited
about it for those of you who do not
know what it is the jr. breakthrough
challenge is a there's a breakthrough
prizes but you can kind of use a new
Nobel prizes where several folks out
here in Silicon Valley
led by Yuri Milner but also a Mark
Zuckerberg and Sergey Brin and Eric
Schmidt they funded this prize it's like
a nobel prize so you know these top
mathematicians and scientists and and
doctors in the world they give a three
million dollar prize for like really you
know disruptions you know breakthrough
type of discoveries and they reached out
to Khan Academy about five six years ago
and said well we want we'd want to do
something for high school students and
what we came up with is what if high
school students created short videos
that explain the phenomenon in math
medicine or science in just a novel way
and if you win the breakthrough prize it
is a lot you get I think it's a 250
thousand dollar scholarship your teacher
gets fifty thousand dollars there's a
hundred thousand dollar lab for your
school so it's like approaching half a
million dollars for a three minute video
so it's a good ROI I think and and I am
one of the judges and you know the ones
that I've always found appealing are
it's always great to have a sense of
humor I would say almost every winner
not every winner but but especially some
you know if you can make someone chuckle
while they're getting their mind blown
you're doing great that's so humor is
great but I think the interest the the
really good one is good ones are psych
even for someone who's an expert or
thought they know about that field like
oh I never thought about it exactly that
way and I think if you can give that aha
and you know many of the judges beyond
me are some of these Nobel Prize winners
breakthrough challenge winners things
like that so if you can make even a
Nobel Prize winner say hmm I'm obviously
an expert at that topic but I never
thought about it exactly in that way and
by the way that was kind of funny I
think you have a good chance of winning
that's that's and I would say it's not
just about the prize just just the
activity of doing it I think is really
really powerful and I think creating
portfolios of things like this
regardless of whether you win or your
finalist you show it to colleges you
show it to employers you show it to
people you're interested in dating and I
think they'll be impressed
so let's see maybe one question okay
I'll take this one from Instagram opium
YUM says how can I become smarter I just
feel like no matter how hard I try I
can't learn anything
well um opium YUM hopefully your
username doesn't correlate too much with
with things going on in your life
because that might be part of the
explanation but in all and all and all
in all seriousness I think you just have
to have a growth mindset about it you
know this notion that somehow
intelligence is fixed is a flawed way of
thinking about it and in some ways
becomes a self-fulfilling prophecy so I
think the best way to quote get smarter
is to engage on things that you can
engage on but are challenging to you and
are a little bit frustrating to you but
what you do is when you find is if you
keep engaging on it for 20 30 minutes a
day 40 minutes a day you're gonna notice
in 2 3 4 months that all of a sudden
that thing that you thought was
difficult you're able to do quite well
it's just like anything it's like going
to the gym or running if you run every
day for 20 minutes and you're gonna
shave minutes off of your mile before
you know it and so I would recommend
Khan Academy is a great place to do it
it's all free it's not all all
non-commercial start at the beginning of
math if you want to start in math and do
one plus one equals two you can use the
course challenges in the unit test to
accelerate you through it and if opium
yum you do 20 30 minutes of that a day
come back in six months and and tell me
if you do not genuinely feel a lot
smarter because I think in about six
months you will have gotten to a grade
level you'll have gotten beyond your
grade level if you're an adult you would
have found that all of those things that
you found intimidating when you were in
you know algebra class whatever you're
like wait that's not so bad now that I
have a good foundation now that I'm
really building a habit of learning it
so I think it's all about having a
growth mindset realizing that you grow
you learn the most when you step out of
your comfort zone you'll you don't
really know how intelligent you are
until you push yourself failing you you
know I like the term fail forward
failing is actually an opportunity for
growth it's actually your best
opportunity for growth and you keep up
with it and and really the sky's the
limit so I'm gonna
stop there this is a lot of fun I could
keep going but you know thank you for
joining this livestream and I will see
everyone on Monday
you